hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast psychiatric
pharmacogenomics practical applications
for the community psychiatrist presented
by dr. Joaquin Benitez clinical
psychiatrist Watson clinic LLP
I'm Christie jollof lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars
presented by laborat the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning now let's get started I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click the
support tab down at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this activity has been planned and
implemented in accordance with the
accreditation requirements and policies
of the Accreditation Council for
continuing medical education ACCME
through the joint provider ship of
global education group and Lavery's
global designates this live activity for
a maximum of one am APR a category one
credit physicians should claim only the
credit commensurate with the extent of
their participation in the activity
in order to receive credit participants
must view the entire webinar and then
complete both the evaluation and
post-test at which time they will be
sent a certificate via email
now like to present today's speaker dr.
Joaquin Benitez dr. Benitez is on staff
at the Watson Clinic serving as a
community psychiatrist in Lakeland
Florida he was formerly a dual appointee
working as an assistant clinical
professor at Weill Cornell University
and at Columbia University in New York
City as part of the attending teaching
staff he was charged with the education
of residents and medical students and
the formation and training of future
thought leaders in the field for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. Benitez you may now begin your
presentation
a pleasant day to all I'm glad that you
have joined us today for this talk this
talk is entitled psychiatric
pharmacogenomics practical applications
for the community psychiatrist as stated
in the title my target audience would be
the typical community psychiatrists like
myself as I practice in a busy busy
community psychiatrist seeing patients
from 9:00 to 5:00 doing
psychopharmacology work allow me to
introduce myself
I am dr. Joaquin Benitez I am on staff
at the Watson Clinic limited liability
practice in Lakeland Florida where I
serve as a community psychiatrist and a
quasi partner on staff seeing on average
16 patients a day prior to that I served
on staff at the New York Presbyterian
University Hospital of Columbia and
Cornell where I held dual appointment as
assistant clinical professor at Weill
Cornell University and that Columbia
University as part of the attending
teaching staff I was charged with the
education of residents and medical
students I was also involved in research
and writing primarily in psychiatric
pharmacogenomics
my academic pursuits have followed me
since my residency training at the Mayo
Clinic where I became involved early on
in pharmacogenomics and their unique
clinical applications under the
mentorship of dr. David Mrazek former
chair of psychiatry at the Mayo Clinic
and one of the fathers of psychiatric
pharmacogenomics
I've had over a decade of experience
using pharmacogenomic tests
providing patients with individualized
and personalized medicine delivering
care using the guiding principle of
giving each and every patient the right
drug at the right dose at the right time
I have had extensive experience working
with very complicated treatment
resistant psychiatric outpatient
referrals having spent several years at
the Payne Whitney partial Hospital
program in Manhattan and now I've taken
this approach with me to my outpatient
practice and Florida where I see a
broader spectrum of community patients
for my disclosures I have no relevant
commercial interest
now what will I be talking about today
in a nutshell
describing how the community
psychiatrist is actually at the vanguard
of the psychiatric pharmacogenomic
practice in our nation
as it is these these site practitioners
who provide care to the patient where it
is most needed it is in this scenario
where we see the day-to-day struggle of
the everyday patient
who encounters treatment resistance for
a plethora of side effects which may
curtail the desire of the average
patient already stigmatized by society
because of their mental illness from
seeking proper psychiatric care
psychiatric pharmacogenomics
is a tool in the armamentarium of the
community psychiatrist to cut through
that treatment resistance limit
side-effects and ultimately improve
outcomes for patients in the community
who experience unnecessary hardships
brought about by their off
difficult-to-treat conditions
there are certain genes and genotypes
which we will review that are relevant
to tests for patients with psychiatric
issues there are practical applications
for these tests which can be justifiably
utilized after repeated treatment
failure or experiencing vicious side
effects and in some cases even prior to
embarking on a medication trial and
finally there are basic resources on
pharmacogenomic drug information that a
well-informed psychiatrist should be
aware of when prescribing psychotropics
that can guide treatment in present in
the present and moving forward now let
me lay the groundwork for the argument
pressive disorder is associated with
significant clinical and economic burden
worldwide in the United States alone we
experience a 16.6% lifetime prevalence
rate
guidelines recommend antidepressant in
conjunction with evidence-based
psychotherapeutic treatment options as
our first line approaches to care
unfortunately not all individuals will
respond to initial treatment many will
fail this subsequently results in trial
and error or heuristic approach to
prescribing which has become part and
parcel of everyday clinical practice
while a blend of communication
common-sense experience and clinical
acumen optimizes the subsequent patient
experience limiting factors such as
situational stress trauma and trance
personality styles and substance use
often limit the likelihood of adequate
outcomes with accepted therapy in the
sequence
alternatives to relieve depression or as
everyone knows it as Darby trials the
rate of response to initial
antidepressant was only forty nine point
six percent
this is a typical situation in
outpatient scenarios to have patients
fail their first stab at an
antidepressant half the time with many
patients experiencing disillusionment
with care some choosing to try a second
medication rest third through the usual
trial and error heuristic others
choosing to drop out of care because of
the aforementioned frustration or a lack
of faith in treatment
moreover annual medical cost for
managing a patient unresponsive to
treatment was nearly ten thousand
dollars more than those for each
treatment unresponsive patient in 2012
adjusting for cost of inflation this
figure would be closer to eleven
thousand five hundred dollars in 2020
projecting for an average of one point
seven seven percent inflation rate
I'm going to talk about my personal
experiences
want you folks to listen to me in my
clinical experience I've seen a lot of
these patients come in deathly afraid
deathly afraid of trying new medication
for the very first time
for very personal reasons including I'm
sure some of you have seen this as well
they say doctor
I want to quote-unquote get better on my
own clothes code or some of them say
doctor I don't want to rely on a
medication I want to do it myself
others tell me they're fine with taking
medications that affect their body such
as meds like metformin because it's fine
they take it for their diabetes or they
might say after I'm okay taking this
inner pill for my hypertension but that
makes they express great trepidation
when they have to take a medication like
fluoxetine because affect my mind or it
might affect the way I think others
refuse medications for religious reasons
and say oh it's against what God might
tell me why I shouldn't take a
medication because God tells me I should
not take it and then it takes me a while
to get them to accept these medications
for their failing mental health I find
consult with me often seen as a court of
last resort with patients stating they
would rather see any other doctor
practitioner other than a mental health
provider it is these patients that I
worry the most about failing treatment
over and over again to begin with there
are already typically ambivalent or
dubious about the visit we often get
only one shot to make a good impression
consider the cost of repeated failure
for these patients emotionally and
psychologically when we continue to go
on using our patented trial and error
heuristic approach to treatment as the
one adult psychiatrist at my clinic
managing the psychiatric needs of a
county that is over 700,000 strong and
that's Polk County drawing from a
referral base of my clinic where the
primary care providers advanced
specialists physician's assistants and
nurse practitioners more than likely
have already tried not just one two
sometimes even three different
psychotropics on these unfortunate
patients the cost of repeated failure in
treatment is so staggering I sometimes
find it a miracle that these patients
continue
back for more treatments after repeated
failures whoo now this is where
psychiatric pharmacogenomics comes in it
is a handy tool in the armamentarium of
the community psychiatrist to cut
through that treatment resistance limit
further burden of side-effects and
ultimately improve outcomes for patients
in the community who experience
unnecessary hardships brought about by
treatment resistance
a caveat pharmacogenomics is no
substitute for an excellent history and
exam many a patient that I've seen
referred to me who had failed multiple
medication trials for depression
actually had a different diagnosis
altogether requiring a different
approach to management I'm sure that
other community psychiatrists and our
audience have seen this time and again
when they have had to discontinue a
patient's California rocket fuel combo
than the faxing and mirtazapine upon
realizing that the patient had three
first-degree relatives of the history of
mania the patient herself exhibited
hypomanic symptoms in at least three
separate occasions in the past another
example would be the patient failing
repro prion 450 milligrams because of
anxiety this person probably could have
benefited from an SSRI instead
pharmacogenetic genomics had evolved
early in the first twenty first century
the first generation of pharmacogenetic
implements were created by roche
laboratories around 2004 when the
cytochrome p 2 d 6 and cytochrome p 2 c
19 were made available
you
cytochrome p 3
for in pharmacokinetic information also
became available as well as SLC 6a for
pharmacodynamic gene these first
generation tools provided genotype and
phenotype accounting for pharmacokinetic
and pharmacodynamic information however
they did not provide information
regarding combinatorial synergies
between variants of genes nor did they
offer clinical interpretation they also
did not offer recommendations or flag
drug drug interactions
looking back I started my residency at
the Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota
in 2004 at the time our department chair
was dr. David Mrazek he was a
forward-thinking academician clinician
researcher and mentor determined at the
time to ensure that his rest including
me were well aware that the bio and bio
psychosocial approaches to care involve
thinking about how pharmacogenomics
played a role in patient response to
care
back then we were encouraged to use the
available technologies when feasible for
our patients including the
aforementioned P 2d six to see 19 p 3 a
4 and SL c 6 a 4 on sub-optimally
responding kishan's
we sometimes even tested for HL a B 1 5
o 12 on Southeast Asians prior to start
carbamazepine
as 15% they develop stevens-johnson
rashes the genotype was prescient
back then however residents and
attendings who are left to interpret the
results of their own
this was a first generation and classic
approach where each test was ordered
individually according to need and as
clinicians we arrived at our own
conclusions independent of laboratory
support the test back then as I recall
were much more expensive and ordered
primarily for patients who we saw on the
inpatient medical service through
consultation liaison or at the inpatient
psychiatric unit where the cost of the
tests could be lumped into the cost of
their inpatient stay for as a super bill
you
it was only years later that the second
generation tools utilizing combinatorial
or poly gene testing approaches that
this thing finally came into prominence
the combinatorial or poly gene approach
was based on evidence that most
antidepressants interacted with multiple
pharmacodynamic and pharmacokinetic
pathways accounting for synergies
between genes included in their testing
panels and providing drug drug
interactions that inform the drug
selection and dosing decisions it also
helped that combining these tests in
packaged products rather than individual
tests that costs were significantly
reduced the test also gradually became
more affordable and accessible to
clinicians as time went on but still it
made more sense to order these tests as
a bundle from third-party testing
companies for the savings it would
entail rather than as individual tests
despite this these tests varied
considerably with each test kit being
subject to its proprietary decision
algorithm which in turn led to a unique
report available to the patient
pharmacogenetics presented may not have
varied considerably but the interpretive
results based on Wade combinatorial
relational gene gene drug gene drug drug
or environmental interactions might have
influenced a recommendation one way or
another at this time
the drug testing being done in the
United States from my experience this is
not a very popular technology elsewhere
in the world I've had opportunities to
liaise with patients and peers
internationally in my career providing
expert care for treatment-resistant
depression in my work at Payne Whitney
with Cornell and at Columbia University
as well as when I was doing expert
second opinion work for international
patients with a barcelona based group
called advanced medical and i think this
has to do with availability in the
united states for insurance coverage for
these testing services as well as other
economic factors that come into play
Chad Boltzmann in his Lancet article in
2016
pointed out that there were 19 options
for clinicians to choose from in the
United States as opposed to three in
Canada 3 in Europe 3 in Asia two in
Latin America 2 in Oceania 1 in the
Indian subcontinent a glaring disparity
of the availability of coverage
there is less support for
direct-to-consumer genetic testing as
three-fourths of psychiatrists believe
that genetic counseling would be
necessary for patients receiving this
information while the manufacturers and
developers of pharmacogenetic tests
advocate for pre-emptive use of their
tools argue that these tools are more
likely to be beneficial to the patient's
if used prior to the usual Trier and
trial and error heuristic to treatment
the standard of practice remains to
order these tests in a reactive fashion
once the patient has failed or has shown
sensitivity to several medications we
can make an argument for the safety of
special populations such as the HLA B
one five zero twelve testing on
Southeast Asians prior to starting
carbamazepine but this is sometimes a
hard sell when you are dealing with
insurance companies in this day and age
when many labs no longer carry
individual tests as they are too
expensive and have to send them out to
places like the Mayo Clinic and the most
cost effective alternative is the
bundled test the honest is often on the
psychiatrist and the patient to provide
evidence through documentation of
treatment resistance or treatment
failure prior to insurance coverage or
for the patient to make a decision to
cover the tests out-of-pocket himself or
herself
you
shameless plug the last paper I wrote
before I left Cornell was how insurance
companies can come up net even and even
avoid spending more money on their
panels of depressed anxious and bipolar
patients by doing pre-emptive
pharmacogenomic testing on their
treatment naive patients
short-circuiting a boatload of
frustration grief to the patient and
saving these insurance companies money
down the road at the patients on their
panel are less subject to morbidity by a
clinic visit and hospitalization here is
a reference that study
of retrospective trials have assessed
the health resource utilization and
potential cost savings for patients with
the use of genetic reports in a
retrospective review shall in 2000 found
that among patients on cytochrome p 2d6
dependent medications those with poor or
ultra rapid cytochrome p 2d6 metabolisms
and between $4,000 and $6,000 more in
one year period through one yo in 2013
retrospectively found that individuals
with reduced cytochrome p 2d6
function average hospitalization length
of stay that was two days longer than
those with normal or increased site
accompli 2d6 function in another study a
retrospective chart review patients that
were on medications predicted to yield
the greatest gene drug complications
presented with significantly increased
total healthcare visits medical absence
days and disability claims resulting in
nearly 5200 greater healthcare
expenditures than those on genetically
appropriate medications that was a joel
winner study in 2013
another study which is a larger scale
analysis of health claims data
that was the one done by [ __ ] Ernest
showed adherence rates and medication
costs using multigenic though not
combinatorial report showing that
patients provided with genetic testing
were significantly more adherent to
their medications compared to standard
of care and that was the Fagor Ness
study done in 2014 based on the
aforementioned studies we can show how
pharmacogenomics adds value from a
fiscal standpoint to psychiatric
practice and does not detract fiscally
there are certain genes and genotypes
which we will review that are relevant
to tests for patients with psychiatric
issues
I had mentioned safe and effective
medications are one of the greatest
challenges in psychiatry large
prospective clinical trials provide
evidence for these challenges with
increasing poor response rates and
intolerance of treatment after a patient
fails one medications which are
exacerbated with each subsequent
medication failure pharmacogenomics
utilizes genetic information to predict
responses to medications on a
personalized level unknown gene drug
interactions for both pharmacokinetic
and pharmacodynamic genes
pharmacokinetic response to
neuropsychiatric medications is largely
driven by the cytochrome p450 enzymes of
enzymes expressed in the liver
metabolism of medications by these
enzymes affects the drug levels in the
blood which will ultimately result in
potential for efficacy and/or side
effects
an individual may be a non expresser
poor metabolizer a normal rat Eliezer a
rapid metabolizers or an ultra-rapid
metabolizer for example an individual
can be a poor metabolizer for a drug
which will result in high drug levels
and increase the potential for side
effects conversely a patient who might
be a rapid metabolizers might suffer
from poor response to treatment due to
some optimal dosing
examples of farm
kinetic jeans and their substrates
include cytochrome p450 2d6 the
following here
fluoxetine venlafaxine nortriptyline etc
cytochrome p to see 19 citalopram a
citalopram amitriptyline and the
following cytochrome p 3 a for every
proposal breakfast papers Ollila perdón
etc cytochrome p to b6 bupropion is a
classic cytochrome p 1 a2 clozapine
olanzapine for promazine
and duloxetine
pharmacodynamic genes predict response
to a medication at the site of action as
an example the serotonin transporter is
encoded by SLC 64 and has two main
allelic variations s and L
patience with an SS genotype have
reduced rates of remission and response
with selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor treatment
conversely patients with an ll genotype
have better responses when using SSRIs a
meta-analysis of four 1435 patients with
the SS allele took longer to respond and
were less likely to achieve remission
compared to controls
both pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
genetic differences contribute to the
variability of response and potential
for side effects for a patient
select medications are exclusively
metabolized by a single gene and will
likely only be pharmacokinetic li
impacted by genetic variation at that
single locus for example cytochrome p 2
d 6 copy number variation has been
demonstrated to have a significant
impact on plasma levels or nortriptyline
which is exclusively metabolized by
cytochrome p 2 d 6 however the majority
of medications are metabolized by
multiple enzymes that can have
considerable variability in receptor and
transport or binding profiles when faced
with this complexity it is now the
psychiatrist decision whether they want
to go with a testing company that
provides a lot of clean information from
single gene tests much in the vein of
the classic testing paradigm or if they
want the testing company to do the
interpretation for them by synchronously
evaluating the combination of
pharmacokinetics pharmacokinetic
pharmacokinetic pharmacodynamic or
pharmacodynamic pharmacodynamic gene
interactions for the individual in
question
you
a classic conundrum for testing the
SSRIs citalopram
this drug is metabolized by three
different enzymes cytochrome p 2 c 19
cytochrome p 2 d 6 and cytochrome p 3 a
4 the main weight is carried by
cytochrome to C 19 however with the to
being secondary additionally the
serotonin transporter SL c6 a 4 is the
pharmacodynamics site of action
identifying genotypic differences
concomitant concomitantly for these four
genes may lead to composite phenotype
for citalopram in one's mind and yield
the most accurate clinically actionable
information for example the patient may
have rapid metabolism metabolism for to
see 19 slow metabolism for both 3 a 4
and 2 d 6 but have l / l as your SL c 6a
for genotype
as I was thinking about it a
combinatorial testing outfit might warn
you against starting citalopram but if I
had seen each gene individually tested
noted that the patient was a young adult
with no heart problems a mother and a
brother who both did well on to Telegram
failed fluoxetine and you Pro peon
previously and wanted the tribus
medication I could very well have celled
my sold myself on the idea of starting
this patient on citalopram based on what
I already knew about the component
information regarding each of the
pharmacokinetic variable dictating
citalopram metabolism and the
pharmacodynamic principle regarding
citalopram SSRI action
to reiterate
one can
to go with a testing company that gives
you component parts to assemble or other
testing companies that provide
proprietary combinatorial algorithms
which purport to give you the best
possible option given the patient's
myriad genetics bury Asians the choice I
believe resides in a clinicians level of
comfort with these tests there are no
right or wrong answers
as a rule of thumb when the need arises
I tend to order the tests that my
patient insurance company will cover I'm
generally pleased with the information I
get with most testing companies out
there again it's really what tests you
can get for the patient's affordably and
what you can make of the information
that counts at the end of the day how
you can make clinical sense of the data
use it to the patient's best advantage
and interpret this information to eat
the patient's recovery and welfare is
all that really matters after all the
test is nothing more than a tool it's of
no use to you or the patient if you
don't understand what it is you're
looking for
or why it is you're looking for that
information in the first place
practical applications as I had
mentioned there are practical
applications for these tests which can
be justifiably utilized after repeated
treatment failure or experiencing a
vicious side effect
in some cases even prior to embarking on
a medication trial pre-emptive testing
is not likely unless the patient has
very deep pockets or the best available
insurance the most likely scenario is
that these tests are ordered after
several repeated or failed trials of a
medication
even justifying a test preemptively for
carbamazepine on Southeast Asians prior
to starting it might not be justifiable
anymore as it is not the first line of
medication we use for bipolar conditions
the gold standard remains depakote and
lithium so both patients usually try
both depakote and lithium in the first
place and fail these medications so the
notion of pre-emptive testing is likely
obviated
most patients anyway would have failed
some medication previously would have
justified some drug sensitivity or
side-effect which would allow one
to order
some other tests previously so
it
renders these things moot and not
helpful there will come a time when you
will encounter a patient who will want
to have these pharmacogenetic tests done
this may be some patient who has caught
wind of genetic testing through a friend
of theirs who had this done elsewhere
for a family member who had success
through care from a different provider
courtesy of genetic testing or had seen
some commercials of direct-to-consumer
genetic tests and have conflated these
tests with the clinical grade tests that
we can provide them if it's our job to
differentiate these tests from from the
ones that they obtained as a direct
consumer test these tests do not provide
the wealth of clinical data that can be
obtained from pharmacogenetic testing
and are not anywhere near as clinically
relevant to their purposes in my
experience I've had some patients come
to my office with their direct consumer
tests with reams of papers binders of
information hoping they can make sense
of what they have thinking that I can
unlock the information contained there
to help them unravel the mystery behind
their secret lives their past histories
unfortunately much to their chagrin and
dismay they're left wanting and
disappointed I don't think we should
chastise or blame these patients for the
misinformation that they've received
rather we should provide them with
support and counsel they come for care
and good evidence-based medicine and you
should provide them with that
are primarily used by community
psychiatrist for major depressive
disorder however a psychiatrist most
cases we see in the community are never
really that clean
as some cases we see have multiple
comorbidities some of these tests also
have applications for ADHD anxiety
bipolar schizophrenia and pain there are
other tests that offer a plethora of
pharmacogenomic information beyond that
which the typical psychiatrists usually
need test reports can extend to multi
system treat disease on how the
patient's pharmacogenomic profile
impacts not just their psychiatric
health but also other systems from
neurology to cardiology to urology
oncology endocrinology GI immunology and
beyond again this depends on the test
company one orders from and the sort of
level of sophistication and complexity
one wants from the test as another rule
of thumb order the test from the company
that you feel will suit your patients
needs best
now I will talk about resources for the
community psychiatrist there are basic
resources on pharmacogenomic drug
information that a well-informed
psychiatrist should be aware of when
prescribing psychotropics that can guide
treatment in the present and moving
forward it is very very easy to get lost
out there as there is a sea of
information regarding drug drug
interactions drug gene interactions drug
environment interactions drugs food
interactions and drug alcohol
interactions if you want to educate
yourself make sure you have a number of
resources available at your desktop and
readily accessible when you need it so
as not to be fumbling when the moment
arises given the wealth of information
out there and the infinite number of
permutations one might see on any given
day working with patients it does not
seem feasible to commit everything to
memory the best strategy it would see
mister start slow and build one mental
database brick by brick until one is
confident with enough information to
detect patterns and relationships
between certain medications and drug
classes that influence each other
for starters one will want to be able to
access good pharmacogenomic information
readily available so as not to get lost
when the moment comes and the decision
to make a man change arrives a really
good online source is the Indiana
University department of medicine
clinical pharmacology table I've been
referring to this table since I started
residency back in 2004 it now goes by
the name of the Flockhart table probably
after some wealthy donor 15 years onward
and it is still going strong it's a
veritable classic if you choose not to
order any genetic testing at least make
sure you're aware of this and the
information contained here in this will
certainly help you navigate the often
complicated world
interactions between drugs substrates
and boosters and inhibitors that we see
in our practice daily I can
also give you many examples of how this
can come to play but here is one
scenario I'm sorry that this slide is
blurred but this is the best image I
could pull online a patient was being
treated with citalopram and bupropion
initially for depression when he didn't
respond was switched to fluoxetine and
bupropion then went to me for consoled
he was not doing well was feeling ill
and lethargic on initial visit what did
you think the issue was I wasn't sure
but I wasn't going to wait for a
serotonin syndrome or seizure nor was I
going to wait for
genetic testing to be done I went
straight away to get my Flockhart chart
the Flockhart chart showed me that both
bupropion and fluoxetine inhibited 2d6
five fold and fluoxetine was mainly
metabolized by 2d6
I could have ordered pharmacogenomic
testing but that would have taken too
long to for results to come I may have
found him to be a slow metabolizer to d6
and that would have been helpful but
either way this was something I decided
to act on independent of testing and I
decided to stop medication
the testing would have given me an extra
layer of information and it would have
been helpful but I decided to act anyway
another good online source of
information is the pharmgkb website this
website is terrific
it is an nih-funded resource that
provides information about how our human
genetic variation affects response to
medications they collect curate and
disseminate knowledge about clinically
actionable gene drug associations and
genotype phenotype relationships on this
website they have information on
individual genes drugs and drug dosing
guidelines all of which come very handy
this is the best and latest in
evidence-based practice another useful
resource is the clinical
pharmacogenetics implementation
consortium drug dosing guidelines the
clinical pharmacogenetics implementation
consortium or ce pick for short it's an
international consortium of individual
volunteers and a small dedicated staff
were interested in facilitating use of
pharmacogenetic tests for patient care a
barrier for implementation of
pharmacogenetic testing in the clinic is
the difficulty of translating genetic
laboratory tests to actionable
prescribing decisions for affected drugs
their goal to address this barrier is by
posting freely available peer-reviewed
evidence-based updatable and detailed
gene drug clinical practice guidelines
they seek to use systematized grading of
evidence and clinical recommendations
using standardized terminology using
peer reviews published and leading
journals and posted on their website
where it's regularly updated
cippec has a key guidelines to a bunch
of things pertinent to psychiatry are
the sea shift to the six variations of
stress atomoxetine h of a variations of
carbamazepine the sip to d6 and ship to
see nineteen variations of several
tricyclics including amitriptyline
remember mean desipramine imipramine try
mep amine and the same variations of
several SSRIs including escitalopram
fluvoxamine sertraline and paroxetine
now
you
you
why is this pertinent because this is
the South same information that you will
find on the FDA drug labels of the
aforementioned drugs particularly in
particularly in this section when they
discuss the pharmacogenetics of these
drugs and how these variances may affect
responses dosing
these guidelines rise to the sort of
scientific scrutiny that one would be
remiss not to know if you neglect this
information beware
conclude I think we all now understand
how important the community psychiatry
is being at the point of the spear of
the psychiatric pharmacogenomics
movement that is in play in our nation
there are more and more patients each
day who avail of these tests and it is
these practitioners in the community who
provide care to the patients who use
these tests the most there's also these
practitioners in these scenarios who
encounter the patients with the greatest
levels of treatment resistance and
side-effects
they are the bastion of hope and the
main bulwark against the community
stigma in psychiatric care we discover
that psychiatric pharmacogenomics can be
a tool in the armamentarium of the
community psychiatrists to cut through
that treatment resistance the mid side
effects and ultimately improve outcomes
for patients in the community who
experience unnecessary hardships brought
about by their off difficult-to-treat
conditions if used wisely of course as I
had mentioned there are limits to
implementation we learned that certain
genes and genotypes were relevant to
tests and there were basic resources on
pharmacogenomics and drug prescribing
information that are useful to end I
would like to thank my colleagues at lab
roots for organizing this and arranging
the logistics and for making this eme a
possible with that I thank you have a
good day and take care I would like now
to open the floor for questions
dr. penis thank you for that informative
presentation it is now time for the live
Q&A if you do have a question you'd like
to ask dr. Benitez please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many questions as we have
time for
okay dr. Benitez our first question is
what sort of qualities do you look for
in a pharmacogenetics test
Chris yeah I'll reveal my biases here
coming from an old-school first
generation approach where we used to do
all these tests individually rather than
how it's done
presently much rather go with testing
where I get a wealth of information
obtaining lots of genes from the patient
leaving me with a freedom to interpret
the information on my own afterwards
rather than going with tests that forced
me to think along the lines of
second-generation combinatorial
strategies which although may be helpful
if one is in a time crunch may be
ultimately limiting if one actually
wants to know what is truly going on
with a patient I honestly can't make any
specific recommendations about which
tests one can get in the market of
course because of the nature of this CME
but one should look to find tests which
will allow one to mine a plethora of
genetic information for their patients
and be alert as possible about these
genes to take the best advantage of the
available information that one can mine
thank you doctor Benitez now let's go
with this question and it's come in a
few times here what do you think of
tests like 23andme and ancestry those
are very interesting and fun
direct-to-consumer tests so in fact my
sister got one for herself and wanted me
to take one myself I told her thanks
this but no thing they are very popular
in this day and age but they do not give
you the necessary information to help
you if a patient asks you if it is going
to be helpful for them and from a
clinical standpoint particularly tell
them to refrain from getting one it is
not going to be helpful to them and it
won't help them make clinical decisions
related to care might help them if they
want to make pop quiz decisions or to
get information about their ancestry and
stuff along those lines but I would not
use that in the informed clinical
decision
thank you doctor Benitez now we're
almost out of time we'll wrap a disc
final question why have ensures or
managed care companies been reluctant to
pay for these pets well some have some
have not I think it boils down to
dollars and cents ultimately once more
research and evidence can be shown as
these tests have actually saving in
saving these companies money and save it
helping save lives reducing morbidity
and mortality and improving patient
outcomes along the way then these
insurance companies might recognize that
these tests might turn their heads and
recognize that these are very good value
propositions and well worth paying for i
I did come up with a study at one point
that showed that this was a value
proposition and several other studies
were were were shown to have proven that
and more more recognition of these tests
will will will prove that in the future
but if it's it's something that will
happen in time ultimately
thank you doctor Benitez now do you have
any final comments for our audience
oh yes actually I'd like to directly to
my references
here they are
a big thank you to dr. Joaquin Benitez
for his time today and his important
contributions to psychiatric
pharmacogenomics I would also like to
thank lab roots for hosting today's
educational webcast
before we go I would also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and lastly one important reminder this
activity has been approved for one am
APR a category one credit if you are
interested in obtaining CMI's for this
webinar please complete the evaluation
and post-test that will appear here
shortly thank you for joining us today
and we hope to see you again soon
bye for now